[Music]
we all have to obey the laws of the
universe whether we like it or not but
what exactly are those laws they can be
a bit complicated to explain and not all
of them are completely understood
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspective several
experts share what we do and do not know
about the strange laws of physics that
govern our universe
we begin now with an example of just how
counter-intuitive these laws can be
enjoy
[Music]
everything in the universe obeys the
laws of physics
so you'd think the laws would be pretty
obvious
you want to know the laws of emotion
just look around see how things are
moving
but of course that's not how it works
the laws of motion are not obvious or
intuitive they need to be learned with
difficulty in school
and they needed to be discovered through
careful experiments and insightful
reasoning
for example newton's first law of motion
says an object in motion will keep
moving in a straight line at a constant
speed forever
unless acted upon by an outside force
but when you throw a ball
it doesn't go in a straight line it goes
up and falls down
when you push on a wagon it doesn't keep
rolling forever
it slows to a stop
it takes a lot of work to keep something
moving in a straight line at a constant
speed
one reason is that we live on a planet
where there's always an outside force
namely the earth's gravitational pull
even worse
we're embedded in a fluid air that
resists the motion of objects
and there's friction between any two
surfaces like a wagon wheel in the
ground
so it takes real imagination to figure
out what would happen if there were no
air resistance and no friction
isaac newton developed a simple theory
four basic laws three laws of motion and
the law of universal gravitation
newton's first law of motion concerns
any object that has no force applied to
it an object not subject to an external
force will continue in its state of
motion at a constant speed in a straight
line now suppose i'm on ice skates right
i'm just standing in the middle of the
rink what's gonna happen
i'll stay in the middle of the rink
but if i'm on ice skates and moving
forward at two miles an hour i will
continue to move straight ahead at two
miles an hour until something pushes me
or stops me
so the first law describes the behavior
of an object subjected to no external
force the second then describes the
behavior of an object that is subjected
to an external force so again if i'm on
ice skates moving forward at two miles
an hour and you push me from behind i
now go faster in the same direction
if you pull me from behind i slow down
if you body check me from the side i
change direction the bigger the push the
more the change the heavier the object
the less the change
so an object is either subject to a
force or it isn't so the first two laws
are sufficient to describe its behavior
but what about the thing that applied
the force what happens to it
the force i feel from you is felt by you
in the opposite direction but in the
same amount right again if i'm on ice
skates and you push me i accelerate
forward because of the force and you go
backwards because of it
if you body check me from the side i
change direction and you go the opposite
way to the penalty box
to every action there's always an equal
but opposite reaction
these three simple laws explained a lot
but they become incredibly powerful when
combined with the fourth law the law of
universal gravitation
which says that gravitation is an
attractive force a very attractive force
the marilyn monroe of physical forces
take any objects with mass and there
will be an attraction between them along
the lines connecting their centers of
mass
this pool will be proportional to the
product of their masses make one twice
as heavy twice the attraction
and it will be inversely proportional to
the square of the distance between them
move them twice as far away
feel only one-fourth the pull
how did newton or anybody ever figure
that stuff out
well in physics class
we learn by watching carefully contrived
physics demonstrations
we watch plastic discs slide across an
air hockey table with very little
friction
we pump all the air out of a chamber to
show that a bowling ball and a feather
fall with the same acceleration
well
mother nature provides us with a physics
demonstration that's visible to everyone
all the time
i'm talking about the motion of the
planets in the sky
to the naked eye
the planets of the solar system are
points of light that move from night to
night relative to the fixed background
of stars
in fact the name planet
comes from an ancient greek word for
wanderer because the planets wander
through the constellations
and it was this celestial physics
demonstration
that led newton to his law of gravity
the planets move in response to the
sun's gravity without any friction
and each one is at a different distance
from the sun
so by observing them you can work out
how gravity depends on distance
imagine standing with a friend who is
holding a flashlight on a dark night at
one end of a long quiet street
standing close to the flashlight it will
appear incredibly bright
however as you walk away from your
friend the flashlight will appear to get
dimmer and dimmer
by the time you've reached the other end
of the street you may barely be able to
see it at all
this experiment demonstrates a
fundamental property of light
known as the inverse square law
which states that as we move away from a
light source its apparent intensity how
bright it looks will decrease in
proportion to the square of the distance
in other words if your distance from the
flashlight doubles
its apparent brightness will decrease by
a factor of four
if your distance triples the brightness
will decrease by a factor of nine
now
imagine that you know the flashlight has
a 20 watt bulb
if you walk away from the flashlight and
use a scientific instrument that can
measure how bright the light is
you could use that apparent brightness
your knowledge of the bulb's wattage and
the inverse square law to calculate how
far you've walked
in astronomy a light source like this
with a known luminosity
is known as a standard candle
if we have a way of determining the
actual luminosity we expect from the
object
we can compare that to the apparent
brightness that we see and measure its
distance
this technique is particularly valuable
when studying very distant objects
eventually the effects of parallax stop
working because things get too far away
if you try the left eye right eye trick
with the distant building or trees on
the horizon odds are you won't see it
move at all
however since a standard candle depends
on the inverse square law it can reach
much further as a result
as long as we have instruments that can
detect a standard candle and measure its
brightness it can be used to measure a
distance
for bright stars like cepheids the
levitt law meant that if we could
measure a cepheid's variation period we
could infer its true luminosity
we could then compare that to its
apparent brightness and use the inverse
square law to calculate how far away it
was
giving us unprecedented reach when it
came to measuring the distances of stars
now you may remember conservation loss
from a high school physics class but the
basic idea is that something is
conserved if it doesn't change
for instance in chemistry an important
conservation law is conservation of mass
if you mix chemicals see a quantity of
hydrogen and a second quantity of oxygen
to make water the mass of the gaseous
ingredients and the final liquid water
are identical
what has happened is that the
ingredients have moved around and been
combined in different ways but no mass
was created or destroyed
in physics you may have heard of the
laws of conservation of energy momentum
and charge
and this is a really subtle and crucial
point the symmetry is in the laws of the
universe not the universe itself i mean
if you walked over to your neighbor's
house to chat over a beer or a nice pot
of tea you'll clearly have changed your
location i mean you won't be in your
house anymore it will be obvious that
you moved
however the question is are the laws of
physics identical in both locations
would a struck bell sound the same would
a cake bake equally well would a ball
fall a fixed distance in the same amount
of time
those are the kind of things i mean when
i say that you make a change and nothing
changes in the laws of physics
so how are these familiar conservation
laws tied into the symmetries of the
cosmos
well let's start with the position of an
object if we can move the position of an
object without the laws of the universe
changing what conservation law does that
lead to it leads to the conservation of
linear momentum
that's right that kind of odd quantity
you might have encountered in a physics
class momentum which equals the mass
times the velocity of an object is
always the same
that's why you used it in problems when
you had two balls of different masses
and velocities hitting one another and
changing directions and speeds the
momentum before and after the collision
is unchanged and now you know that this
arises from the fact that the laws of
motion are independent of where you do
the experiment
another symmetry of the laws of nature
are that they are unchanged if we change
what we define as day zero
the gregorian calendar defines the first
day is just a bit over two millennia ago
suppose we defined the second at which
the clock struck midnight on the night
that split 1999 and the year 2000 as
moment zero
if the laws of physics looked at that
shift in time and yawned and went back
to sleep unchanged
then that means that the laws of physics
are symmetric under shifts in time
the corresponding conservation law is
the law of conservation of energy
so the first big idea in thermodynamics
is the familiar idea of energy every
separate part of the universe we we call
that a system has a certain energy
content which we denote by e
the the physics unit of energy is the
joule roughly speaking that's the energy
of motion that a baseball acquires if
you drop it a couple of feet
energy can change forms and be
transferred from one system to another
but the total amount of it remains
constant energy cannot be created or
destroyed it's conserved
that's the first law of thermodynamics
systems can exchange energy and this
happens in two distinct ways the first
way is called work
w
this is energy transfer that is
associated with a force acting through a
distance like the force of gravity
acting on the baseball after you drop it
less obviously work is also done when
you charge up an electric battery or
when a material becomes magnetized it's
all work
the second way that energy is
transferred is called heat
that's q
if you put two bodies at different
temperatures next to each other there is
a heat flow from the hotter one to the
colder one that that energy transfer
isn't work since the objects are not
exerting forces or being moved
that's heat flow
and according to the first law
a system's energy cannot just go up or
down on its own there must be some kind
of energy transfer
to or from the system so the total
change in the system's energy
delta e
is just the heat plus the work
q plus w
and we should notice here that q and w
could each be positive or negative
depending on whether the energy is
flowing into or out of the system
now as far as the first law is concerned
any sort of energy transformation or
exchange is fine it does not matter for
instance whether heat flows from hot to
cold or cold to hot either way obeys the
law but in the real world
heat only flows from hot to cold and
never the reverse or or take another
example
we can always transform work into heat
if i if i rub my hands together
they warm up
friction turns muscular work into heat
that the reverse is not always possible
we cannot always turn heat into work
now we can do that to some extent that's
how a steam engine works
heat from a fire boils water and the
steam pushes a piston but not all of the
heat is turned into work some of it is
released into the cooler surroundings as
waste heat and and try as we might we
cannot build an engine that turns heat
into work with 100 efficiency
so there is another principle at work
besides the first law
and that's exactly what the german
physicist rudolf klausius discovered in
the mid 19th century the second law of
thermodynamics
and to express his new law clausius
introduced a strange new quantity called
entropy
s
the word derives from the greek word
tropos meaning transformation so so what
is this mysterious entropy
it's a property of a system like its
mass or its energy content
s can change
as the system undergoes changes it may
increase or decrease and entropy moves
from one system to another when heat is
transferred
clausius's second law says that the
total entropy can never decrease
total s can stay the same or it can go
up but it can never go down
put even more simply the universe is
always becoming more random
any homeowner can attest to this simple
principle
just like the house of cards a wall or a
mountain
if left to reach its own lowest energy
state a house will eventually crumble
into a disordered pile of rubble
so how do we prevent this change
well significant energy must be put in
by the homeowner to keep the system in
its desired macro state
this is because there are far more
microstates consistent with that
unattractive pile of rubble than there
are with a beautiful home
so every time you clean the kitchen
patch the roof or mow the lawn you are
fighting entropy it's a battle that you
can continue indefinitely
as long as you have an external source
of energy in this case that source
is you
this is particularly disconcerting from
a cosmological perspective since
cosmologists often think about the
entire universe as one gigantic closed
system
if we think in this way boltzmann's
equation and the second law of
thermodynamics make a dire prediction
that the overall randomness of matter in
the universe will constantly increase
until it simply can't anymore
since in theory there's nothing outside
of the universe to act as a source of
energy input
we're doomed by the second law of
thermodynamics
this manner of thinking leads to the
prediction that someday the universe
will become completely randomized a
slave to the second law of
thermodynamics
its entropy will continue to grow and
grow until the whole of the universe is
one single uniform temperature
at this point there will be no available
energy left to power life planetary
processes or even the vast engines of
stars
cosmologists call this phenomenon heat
death
and if it's our destiny then the only
consolation is that it's going to take
the universe billions and billions of
years to get there
in recent decades physicists once again
have become interested in theories that
could potentially combine and unify
multiple facets of nature
in spirit these modern theories have a
lot in common with einstein's dream of
unified field theory
but in other ways they are really very
different
for one thing many important discoveries
have been made since einstein's death
and these discoveries have significantly
changed how physicists view the prospect
of building a unified field theory
in particular whereas einstein was
focused on electromagnetism gravity
physicists have since discovered two new
forces that exist in nature as well the
weak and strong nuclear forces
the strong nuclear force is a force that
holds protons and neutrons together
within the nuclei of atoms
and the weak nuclear force is
responsible for certain radioactive
decays and for the process of nuclear
fission
it turns out electromagnetism has a lot
in common with these strong and weak
nuclear forces
and it's not particularly hard at least
in principle to construct theories in
which these three phenomena are unified
into a single framework
such theories are known as grand unified
theories or guts for short
and since they were first studied in the
1970s a number of different grand
unified theories have been proposed
grand unified theories are incredibly
powerful and in principle they can
predict and explain a huge range of
phenomena but they're also very hard to
test and explore experimentally
it's not that these theories are
untestable in principle if you could
build a big enough particle accelerator
you could almost certainly find out
exactly how these three forces fit
together into a single unified field
theory
but even grand unified theories
are not as far-reaching as the kinds of
unified field theories that einstein
spent so much of his life and career
searching for
grand unified theories bring together
electromagnetism with the strong and
weak forces
they don't connect these phenomena with
general relativity
but much like einstein modern physicists
are also looking for theories that can
combine general relativity with the
other forces of nature
we hope that such a theory could unify
all four of the known forces including
gravity
and since the aim of such a theories
describe all of the laws of physics that
describe our universe we call a theory
of this kind a theory of everything
i sometimes wonder what einstein would
think about our modern investigations
into grand unified theories and theories
of everything
in many ways these modern theories have
very little in common with those
explored by einstein during his lifetime
but in spirit they're really trying to
answer the same kinds of questions
at their foundations they are each
trying to explain as much about our
world as possible as simply as they
possibly can
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here